[Applause]
all right we're all checked in we've got
our boarding passes ah this has been so
stress-free i can't believe how easy
this trip has been so far i feel like
though we've forgotten something
where are the kids
oh
boys where are you get in the car
thomas
get in the car what
nathan get in the car
jacob
get in the car get in the car get in the
car get in the car go go
all right is everybody in the car yeah
[Music]
all right guys time to go to the uk
that's right we're gonna spend five
weeks in the uk we're gonna tour england
wales scotland and northern ireland
we're gonna be spear fishing camping
seeing castles and seeing lots of cool
stuff but first we have a very long
plane ride
travel montage
[Music]
hey well guys we made it to heathrow
[Music]
but the fire alarm went off
did our kids have anything to do with it
i don't think so i'm not 100 sure well
while they're sorting out the fire alarm
in the airport we got to go find our
rental car
here we go we got our car
oh
we got ourselves a 9 passenger diesel or
is this a peugeot or something i don't
know
all right let's try driving on the
left-hand side of the road this feels
weird
hi bud
hey matt melanie those of you don't know
this is my sister melanie she's joining
us on this trip
okay
i can't remember if it's slow people on
the left or slow people on the right
here so i'm gonna go down the middle had
to stop and get some diesel
117 pounds to fill up the tank it's
about 150 dollars it's a little pricey
there's stonehenge
stonehenge is just in the field on the
side of the highway
just right there
dang it
look at that
all right guys we've been on the side of
the road for about two hours and this
lovely gentleman here is going to get us
a new tire and mountain balance it right
here
and i am so grateful but we got a new
tire we got it remounted on the rim and
balanced and everything and it only cost
200 bucks
that's not bad for a saturday night
because it's 1am but we made it to the
house
[Music]
all right it's late i've got to get the
kids to bed so i'm going to put the
camera down and first thing in the
morning we're giving you a tour see you
in the morning
[Music]
this isn't too shabby isn't it oh my
gosh this is gorgeous you can see a
beach just a little bit through the
trees is the ocean over there little
village of was it salcombe
salcombe there's some crumpets with
black currant reserves some madeline
sausage lardons
uh tomatoes hot cross buns
i forgot to buy butter
here's one boy baby
peanut butter chocolate
welcome to your writing location
my sister's a professional novelist and
she's going to be doing a lot of writing
on this trip so we have to have a
writing location for becca this is her
painting spot
we're gonna head off
to church so we're gonna drive to the
nearest big town which is plymouth as in
where the mayflower left off of it's
actually scarier in the daytime
well we had an absolutely wonderful time
going to church here in plymouth but
we're going to drive around a little bit
and just see some of the countryside all
right we're gonna go to the mayflower
steps in plymouth
oh my gosh look at those buttresses this
must be one of those gothic chapels look
at that look at that bombed out church
there's the mayflower steps over there
here becca you go runway park illegally
16
20.
you guys had ancestors on the on the
mayflower on both sides of your family
the jumpers are fun they actually say
they watch outdoor boys so that's kind
of fun
this actually brings back some memories
being becca came here to plymouth the
first time in 2012 uh and this is
actually our fifth trip as a family to
the uk i had fish and chips for the
first time ever here in plymouth they
were good too yeah
all right
well we've got a few hours left in this
beautiful sunday so i've got a gopro
here on the front of the car and we're
gonna go for a little drive through this
beautiful countryside let's do it
well let's see if the camera flies off
the front of the car here this will be
fun
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
that was fun but i'm tired i need to go
to bed
good morning i am hungry
check it out david that's that's squash
that's current apple squash
good that's good yeah the foliage right
there
that's brilliant it's so good i've been
looking forward to this you got some
fried fried mushrooms there some veggie
sausage
do you like that
that's good
you're gonna have this jacob
did you like
this is actually a fun little place to
eat breakfast if you guys want to come
here or see details about any of the
stuff we do on our trip check out the
video description for links below
wrong side
all right baby here's the keys to the
house
me and melanie are going to hit the
grocery store all right thank you
we're here at the tesco which sounds
like a gas station but it's not it's a
grocery store
they have such good butter here
check it out banana flavored weetabix
i'm gonna give that a shot crunchy
peanut butter marmite you remember this
devin custards right there
all right we get some rebecca
oh those are good
check it out it's a cake the shape of an
xbox controller
that's crazy
ooh hob knobs
i get more crumpets
apple cinnamon hot cross buns
ah jaffa cakes
jammy dodgers
hey does the wheels make it harder
turn left on the cookworthy court
well tom we need to get ready for our
fishing trip okay
well me and tommy are going surf fishing
oh we tonight here a little bit early so
we're gonna go kind of look around a
little bit oh that's stiff yeah
that's got some backbone yeah slingshot
for shooting bait out into the water
oh look at those those are creepy
you want to play with that tom no you
want a pet worm no
that is horrifying that's my nightmare
now they sell nightmares by the pound
yeah that's it yeah
go how about this all right guys so
we've got wayne and his son finley here
and uh wayne's gonna take us out sea
angling we're gonna go surf fishing
see about catching some fish here
uh off the beach hopefully yeah give it
a go
well guys welcome to chester beach
well it's pretty nice right now but uh
that weather over there doesn't look so
friendly i think we get a little rain
you know it's a little cliche but you
know you go to england you got to get
rained on right
now tom if you start to get cold you
just let me know and i can heat up the
car and get you in there okay and then
what we do we bind it on
to the hook that is a tight little
package of crab gu
oh he come off well where there's one
there's usually a ton
oh yeah you found some more fossils that
does look like a fossilized fish scale
there's fossils all over the beach we're
really close to the jurassic coast and
in about three days we're gonna go
fossil hunting there with the family and
look for big old
fossilized seashells and stuff
the weather is turning particularly
nasty here and tommy's getting cold so
tom and finley are gonna go in the car
and warm up a little bit
holy mackerel
look at that i got two little back girls
all right let's go see if we can get
another one
they usually
it's the bone of a cuddle fish
they just washed up on the beach all
right back to catching mackerel
oh
there we go not too bad
well wayne thanks so much we had a ball
that was
that was fun i'm glad we did it listen
guys if you're ever in the southwest of
england and you want to do this too make
sure to check out wayne i'm going to put
his information down the video
description below including his youtube
channel the shower hunter so check that
out thank you for coming over thanks for
booking me i'm gonna get tommy to bed
it's it's late all right guys i'm gonna
put down the camera i got some driving
to do
well we made it home safe it's late i'm
going to bed i'll see you guys in the
morning
good morning guys
[Music]
look at the size of these blackberries
here
so it is another beautiful day and we're
gonna do about a one hour drive to more
well and key
all right we made it
this place was like an old copper mine
it's like real life minecraft
they used to mine arsenic here that's
enough to kill like 50 people hey
melanie check it out these are the old
chains they used for crossfit back in
the days
yeah look at that oh there's the cooper
shop that's how they make the barrels
this is where they would make make
coffins wait so i actually did buy
inside no no
no no bathroom oh there's a mother ew
just sleeping on that these are little
kid beds
that's how you go to the potty at the
middle of the night
there's actually an underground mine
here and a mine tour and there's a
little train you can take into the mines
but that's still shut down from covid so
we're just kind of checking out what's
open
oh it's mine
i'm scared
is that what they put in the oh this is
a giant lime kiln where they would take
limestone and burn it up and turn it
into quick lime to make mortar out of it
wow
oh look at this are there toys that they
play with
sometimes you gotta stop and smell the
roses do you want some ice cream yeah
clotted cream ooh coffee fudge generous
thank you very much well you like the
honeycomb
there's a lot of ice cream swapping
going on here
you nathan you want to go to the play
area
all right before you guys watch it go
show everyone what's in the play thing
okay
and all the children they're actually
heading towards the car is the play
place your favorite part
all right i'm going spear fishing
tomorrow and i need to pick up a few
things so i'm going to stop at the spear
fishing store real quick we're just
trying on a wetsuit here
now that i've made everyone throw up in
their mouth a little bit i need to go i
need to go take take this off well there
you go i bought way too much spear
fishing stuff for our trip tomorrow and
i'm kind of hungry you guys want to get
some food yeah
what are you doing you getting at it
it's like watching a tapeworm get passed
okay here we go
yeah thank you there's anything else i
can get four years ago that looks pretty
good huh thai curry here we're gonna try
that
oh steak and mushroom pie that looks
good
all right we're back at the house and i
gotta get myself packed and ready
because i'm going spear fishing early
tomorrow morning
[Music]
how you doing nice to meet you nice to
meet you
i've got max here with the frenchman
spearfishing course and i've got harvey
here with the youtube channel spearfin
and we've got john and sam we're gonna
be helping make sure that i don't drown
myself too yeah yeah let's go poke a
fish
i gotta tell you what folks this is a
different way to see england
look at that you just found that right
there you tasted control i've never had
them raw
yeah it's a nice one
oh thank you
just sweet and salty
yeah
that is really good moment of truth time
to jump in
[Music]
[Music]
yeah there's like a old abandoned crab
trap in there they're just full of the
crabs
got a few crabs ate a scallop
we're off to roaring start
little signal there
alright
well there's quite a bit of down there
huh
all right we're gonna try something a
little different we're gonna dive and
see if we can't find some lobsters
thank you
foreign
um
[Music]
i don't mean to brag harvey but i'm kind
of the spider crab king now
i don't make the rules
i think i have enough use of my fingers
now i can fillet the fish
there we go
a couple pulley flakes if you want to
check out a youtube channel if somebody
actually knows what they're doing check
out harvey's youtube channel spearfin
and i'll put a link in the video
description below and if you guys want
to come over here and do this too make
sure to check out max's charter business
got a bag of spider crabs and some fresh
pulling again it's time to head back
home
i'm gonna turn the heater way up
is that warm and fuzzy
what do you think
[Music]
if i want to play
look at that big chunk of meat these are
like king crab bodies with little snow
crab legs on them but they're still
there's loads of meat on these
ah i'll tell you what that crab was
delicious but i am exhausted i am gonna
go upstairs to take the longest hot
shower i can
and i'll see you guys in the morning
pretty nice isn't this babe
it's beautiful big
history stuff yay
welcome to buckland abbey
becca milly's got the kids let's leave
take care of the children
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh
so apparently this abbey was purchased
by sir francis drake who's famous for
defeating the spanish armada at cadiz so
a lot of stuff about his life is here
his sword's probably in here somewhere
there's secret staircases
yeah yeah
don't touch it don't touch it
[Music]
arms that sounds super british
right in the corner jake take it out
it's a katsu burger yeah that'll work
all right that was delicious
we're gonna check out a fancy pantsy
hills
[Music]
the heads of executed traders were
displayed on spikes okay you don't have
to go home but you can't stay here
[Music]
you guys had fun yeah
[Music]
well we're back at the house and uh me
and tom are going for a little walk down
to the beach
hey i'm dry
oh there's oh that's a big olympic tom
fresh a little bit of limit
look at that it's an old piece of
pottery look at that there's a whole lot
of history here
oh we're having a good time but we have
got to get to bed we are getting up so
early tomorrow morning we're going
fossil hunting it's gonna be awesome
it is 4 30 in the morning and we're
going fossil hunting
one of those should work out
all right guys we're here at charmouth
beach i'm here with martin with jurassic
coast guides and he is going to take us
fossil hunting and what are the like the
most common fossils we see here like one
of these oh look at this so that's a
bellum knight oh ammonite okay that's
the one i was kind of visual yeah the
teammates commonly found things on the
beach he also set water in for his mouth
there fired that jeep and swam backwards
what information is chris giving you to
help find him on the beach
it's the last and final fossil
yeah why are you saying p well you are
100 right that is fossilized poo all
right guys you ready to do some fossil
honey yeah yeah all right let's do it
oh yeah taking down to make sure there's
no other bits of
ammonite stick if you see that on the
beach then you want to step up and not
just dive like so
oh look at that that is really good
texture on that one
you got one
now look there's a little one right
there can you see it
right there oh that's a big one
little chunk of a very large ammonite he
said that was one inside the rock bellum
knight in some matrix that's way cool
babe
oh nathan found the star one
look how much of these oh my god there's
tons of them and i would love to drive
go oh that's a wonderful one becca
yes
look at that
i think that's the best one so far
how big that must have been
so what did the female dinosaur call her
blouse making sure i don't know try
sarah's tops oh
thank you very much
let's put all the fossils over here and
see see what we got
here not quite everything
oh we got tons and tons of these
bellamites melanie gets the award for
the biggest complete one oh becca gets
the coolest one for this finding the
bellamite in matrix this is probably the
coolest one right here oh that's mine
and of course the best catch of all
these are little christenoids yeah and
nathan found him he was the christinoid
king look how perfectly star shaped
those are i'll tell you what if you guys
ever want to try fossil hunting
especially if you want to do it here in
the south of england this little class
was awesome and as you can see
we cleaned up well that was fun but
before we leave we're going to go ahead
and check out the fossil museum
is that cool look at the size of that
thing oh look how well preserved that is
what a great ichiosaurus jackpot
those giant skulls
so becca you think that was worth
getting up at 4 30. it was oh god
i am hungry is anyone else hungry
yes tommy
what do you think of that is that good
tom yes
mom you like your crepes
you happy very good thank you should we
go check out a bookstore so me and becca
have a tradition that every time we go
to a different country we like to buy a
kids book there so we're gonna go ahead
and get some kids books for the boys do
you guys want to get this bookstore
we got bino and dandy
action adventure true stories that's
cool
you guys you guys want to buy this
you know things are a little different
in british restaurants you go and find
yourself a seed at these pubs
figure out what you want to eat go up
and you order it tell them what table
you're sitting at and you pay for it up
front then you can just walk out when
you're done
i'm hungry
you get pizza cutters we got a moroccan
lamb curry here
good burger is hard to beat that was
pretty yummy wasn't that yeah
[Music]
well guys we're back at the house and
we're cleaning up and packing up because
tomorrow morning we're checking out
and heading up to wales we're going to
see a whole another part of the united
kingdom and i'm looking forward to it
we've got a lot of work to do so i'm
going to put up the camera i'll see you
guys in the morning
and we're headed north about four hours
north to the country of wales and along
the way we're to stop and see some
castles you guys want to see some
castles yeah yeah
souls
here we made it to barry palmeroy castle
fun fact barry pomeroy and the vicarage
here is where becca's ancestors some of
them were christians
[Music]
what do you think guys is that pretty
cool yeah i'm gonna go home again
we're here at the gift shop to the palm
roy castle and uh we came across some
armor and i think it's time to do our
thumbnails
we we caught swords
we got our thumbnail good job templar
hey melanie you got some lunch for us oh
yes some clotted cream and scones and
berries we got you a brie and apple
chutney sandwich oh that looks amazing
tommy do you like using actual armor and
actual swords in an actual castle yeah
that was amazingly fun clotted cream and
scones amazing
all right boys to the car
well since we're in barry palmeroy we
decided to swing by the vicarage here
and becca's gonna check out a place
where her uh ancestors were christened
here you go babe take the camera this is
beautiful
beautiful church
i'm glad i could peek inside
they indulged me for a quick stop that
was fun
all right we're gonna go see raglan
castle in wales
we're stuck behind a truck that belongs
to the north
staffordshire racing pigeon federation
go pigeons go go go
welcome to wales
all right let's go check out the castle
oh that's uh that's quite the castle
welcome to raglan castle here in wales
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do you like that castle yeah that was a
cool castle really cool that's cool as
always we're gonna put the links to all
the cool stuff we do in the video
description so you can see more about
that there
well we're almost to a rental house and
we need to pick up some more food so me
and tommy to run into the grocery store
okay
nothing of ours that was hard things
[Music]
all righty
yeah
still so nice
oh
oh my goodness it's big
oh
these are not the code oh look at this
well this is spacious
oh look at this
oh this is nice becca's gonna like this
you like this is this a good writing
space
look at that view
yeah
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and shut the
door to keep the heat in okay
all right everyone's hungry so we're
gonna eat something quick we're gonna
make hot dogs and so we've got hot dogs
in the jar
and uh some fresh curry dogs as well
who wants hot dogs
that's really good that is real good do
you like your helmet yes we need to get
you to bed
well it's getting late i've got to fill
up some hot water bottles and get the
kids ready for bed i will see you guys
tomorrow morning
well guys it is an absolutely gorgeous
sunday morning
the uk love switches they put extra
switches on everything
toaster not working
there's a switch do you want to use your
oven
there's a switch for that do you want to
use this outlet
there's a switch for that too if you
want to use the shower there's an extra
switch there's switches there and they
look just like the light switches so if
you ever plug something in and it
doesn't work look for a switch gonna
wear that to church there i'm not sure
it's still allowed but if it's a yes
i'll take it
sir dab a lot
a beautiful sunday breakfast
look at this dapper group of yankees
there are a few things more gorgeous
than driving through the british
countryside on a beautiful sunny spring
day if we can get rid of the kids me and
becca will rent a convertible one of
these days
oh they're fluffy
keeping with tradition we're not going
to v-log the service i'll see it a
little bit
did you have fun yeah yeah let's go back
to the cottage and eat loads of food and
not move or drive i'm tired we're just
having a nice low-key day i'm just gonna
get some rest because we've been burning
the candle on this trip
[Music]
chicken and spaghetti for lunch
allow me what's so good
oh it is so nice melanie and becca are
sitting here enjoying the sun room and
watching bonnet flicks together
and the boys are outside having fun
but there's tom with his sword
all right i'm gonna try a tea cake here
oh look at that oh
[Music]
it's a white chocolate nestle line bar
it's like a twix with a crunch bar mixed
together what do you what do you got
tommy british waffles they're like eggos
that you don't need to refrigerate
toffee bon-bon
well darn good melanie and becker
watching the old sense accessibility
with emma thompson because that was over
at the sulcum house
sultrum house that we saw earlier
i shall have it knocked down to make way
for a grecian temple each one of these
books are really expensive
this day has just kind of devolved into
sitting in the sun room eating junk food
and uh hanging out watching shows
together as a family this has been
pretty nice babe have we eaten too much
food yes too much sugar should we go to
bed yes
we're in milford haven in southwest
wales
[Music]
and i'm here with dave george and
richard with pembrokeshire boat charters
and we are going to go poke a fish and
i'm really excited because the weather's
actually really nice today
there we go just driving through the
locks getting out of the harbor
a little seal right over there
all right
well there's plenty of spider crabs
a oh beach ball
so
[Music]
little baby fish
try to look graceful
ready well check it out david here is
cooking up some lunch
huh yeah well it looks like a little
squished scone a little bit well guys
i'm full of bacon sandwiches and
wonderful welsh cakes here and we're
gonna go try another little spot and see
if we can't find a sea bass
[Music]
so
saw some gorgeous scenery a ton of
spider crabs and loads of pollock
well dave tells me there's an island
with some puffins on it we're gonna go
check that out before heading back in
you can see all these little puffin
burrows up at the top of the cliff
there's these big black back seagulls
and they're swooping down and
eating puffins oh yeah yeah
they seem remarkably chill about the
fact that they're just getting picked
off one by one but we're running out of
time so we're gonna head back to the
marina and
i'm proud to say that i'm not freezing
[Music]
if you guys are in southern wales and
you'd like to do a spear fishing trip
like this or any sort of boat charter
trip check out pembrokeshire
boatcharters.co.uk i'll put a link in
the video description below all right
hey guys thank you very much
your destination is on the left
oh you guys have been painting
no that looks like a hardcore night oh
oh yeah i might have picked up a little
treat for you guys well we're back home
and i am gonna make some fish curry
[Music]
um
so what do you guys think of the curry
good oh it's good
i speared it for you it's the end of a
wonderful day and i'm sitting here with
a hot water bottle under my shirt and i
will see you guys in the morning we got
more awesome stuff to do tomorrow
good morning good morning
[Music]
all right melanie where are we going
today st fagan's national museum of
history
i want to hug that sheep well guys
welcome to save fagins this is a
sprawling outdoor museum where they have
lots of old buildings that they've
transported here they also have like
lots of activities for kids and
demonstrations of different crafts and
trades kind of think welsh williamsburg
oh my goodness
oh that that fire feels really nice
these are old beehives what do we got in
here it's a two-seater outhouse
smells like pig in here yeah there's a
reason
there's a fair number of people here but
uh it's a beautiful day it's free and
it's kind of cool so i get it
on the list of things my wife loves like
lighthouses fairies flash roof cottages
and family they would collect
the tall
two cheesies a slice of of the stuff
with the butter
[Music]
lemon curd preserve
yeah got lemon curd butter
you like that
have another bite who wants a piece of
lemon curd bread melody yeah
that was wonderful
[Music]
gotta do the coconut game right all
right
oh
there we go yeah
i get a coconut this one
oh it's so cute
[Music]
oh
yeah i'm too heavy
[Music]
go for it
[Music]
[Music]
well that was a pretty cool little place
for free yeah should we go see car
philly castle yeah yeah
[Music]
all right guys we're in cardiff
[Music]
and we're going to car philly castle
which is one of the most intact and
largest castles in the uk nathan was
just a little baby last time we were
here
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you thank you for the toys
hey jacob do you want to find a kid's
book
i need a new bum
my mom is so noisy nathan do you need
this one we got some books there well we
had a good time at the castle we bought
some kids books we also got a whole
bunch of hot water bottles with cozies
but now we're gonna go get some dinner
and we're in the mood for british style
indian food yeah yeah let's do it
your destination is on the right
we ordered a little bit too much maybe
it smells amazing
that delicious that's so delicious
so good
we're checking out tomorrow morning and
heading up to northern wales
so i'm gonna put the camera down and get
packing help put some kids to bed
[Music]
make sure to eat all those blueberries
guys can't take them with us
all right guys welcome to the manon
abbey hotel in northern wales
[Music]
this is actually pretty affordable i
think it was cheaper than getting a
house if i remember correctly all right
guys it is late and i've got to put this
camera down and help becca wrestle three
boys into bed
well good morning i think it's time to
go get some breakfast
thank you very much
you got a blood sausage black pudding
we got some fried toast mushrooms
tomatoes sausage bacon you gonna try the
black pudding
yeah just a teeny bite
[Music]
now originally we planned on staying two
nights and we were gonna do a fishing
charter today but the fishing charter
got canceled and we decided that we're
gonna leave and head up to scotland
today instead of tomorrow but anyway
let's get packed up get out of here
i studio so we just drive north towards
scotland and see what happens
let's do it
so i put glasgow in our gps or sat nav
as they say in the uk and we're gonna
take only back country roads we want to
see the landscape and it's going to take
us through liverpool and through the
lake district
we had a lovely time in wales but we're
back in england now
all right guys welcome to liverpool
[Music]
yeah apparently they're into something
called football here in liverpool i
don't know football matches last a
billion hours apparently
well tomorrow is the queen's platinum
jubilee and so it's a four-day weekend
here and everyone's celebrating and
pulling out their union jack bunting and
flags and everything it's kind of fun
watching everyone celebrated
eating our gummies while we're stuck in
traffic we got gummy sheep and gummy ice
cream cones
looks like we're gonna drive through the
lake district that's some place we've
always wanted to visit
[Music]
oh it is so crowded here in the lake
district with the four day weekend
everybody's coming
we're now in scotland our third country
in our uk tour their country today
we're just looking for a parking space
well we were in the car for about six
hours and we drove all the way to a
little outside of glasgow scotland
[Music]
but we barely found a hotel everyone in
their pet dog is out having a good
holiday with the four day weekends
look at this it's a wall of beds if they
roll off it'll just be fine all right
guys i got three boys to bed it's time
to say good night
i'll see you guys in the morning
all right we got everybody in
that with you
very nice well high on our agenda today
is to get me a suit but not just any
suit i need a british suit a very
british soup oh wow ooh looking good
that's a nice tweet we got suits we
gotta get moving well yeah we were much
later than we told melody
whole shell french cake all right babe
we got some food
we got you some beans
oh the mac and cheese baked pie pretty
good oh yeah
all right guys i need to go take tommy
and buy a kilt becca wants to go see the
castle with the two little ones so we're
gonna do a little divide and conquer
so now that we're in scotland we want to
go ahead and get tommy a kilt he's grown
out of the one we got on our last trip
to scotland
he accidentally runs up that's nice oh
maybe that is a bit bigger actually
you're looking good tom do you like that
this one's just perfect
you want to hold that for me yes
meanwhile
[Music]
well that was fun but i think it's time
to leave sterling and head about two
hours west to open
exit the roundabout onto a84
[Music]
[Music]
a proper shower and a cup
[Music]
grab a piece and take it to the table
we've got to get to bed we've got an
early morning tomorrow the whole family
we're going snorkeling
yeah in scotland
the new seems got in the car i freaked
out
we are going out with basking sharks
scotland dot co dot uk and we couldn't
ask for a more gorgeous perfect day look
at this
get through the big poop party
there's some dolphins right by the boat
oh right there yeah look at it a whole
bunch of them right over there
there's probably 20 or so at least that
we see
yeah there we go
oh yeah you can see them
rebecca is this cool
oh
[Music]
that was cool
check it out guys it's fingal's cave
it's the end of the giant's causeway
it's a rock formation that starts in
northern ireland goes under the ocean
and ends here in the islands of scotland
we're gonna get to swim inside it
look at these cool rock formations now
this is twinkle's cave the whole island
is the isle of
staff pretty cool ellie
one hand oh i got you from behind
hey
this is the giant's cave
look at all of the roof here
i'm so scared
the giant owns this place yeah hexagon
trying to i'm trying to
you got one all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what do you think babe that's amazing
i'm so glad we did that
i think it's like a seaweed like oh oh
yeah there's plants coming out of my
face well that's spiegel's cave now
we're gonna go to another spot where
there's a little bit calmer so we might
be able to get the boys in the water i
am a lot warmer than i was down in
cornwall i'll tell you a nice sunny
beautiful day makes all the difference
oh look at that water jake look we got
yours
you look like a medieval peasant there
oh look at those cute little cheeks it's
just so
[Music]
jake just abandoned me
[Laughter]
there we go
[Music]
there's a seal over there is that cool
yeah
[Music]
hey tell me do i do it in yeah was it
cold yes what was the coolest thing you
saw probably the seals
got all three of them you're brave
i see the egg i see it
i love penguins they're ghillie mugs
oh
[Music]
you got your hot water bottles
i got two
well check it out at the little village
of toba mori on the island of mall
we were here in 2019 still as lovely as
i remember
scottish cake of some sort we're gonna
try that i packed some amazing lunches
yesterday and forgot it all in the
refrigerator so we got some food
oh and uh we might have found a massive
battenberg
is that fun
yeah listen if you're ever in urban
scotland and you'd like to snorkel with
basking sharks or swim with seals or go
to phoenix cave or do any of the stuff
you saw us do check out
baskingsharksscotland.co.uk i'll put a
link in the video description below to
their website are you guys tired yeah oh
i am so tired
i don't think we're gonna do much more
today other than just relax so i'm gonna
put up the camera and i'll see you guys
bright and early tomorrow morning
oh the gnats are bad today my witch is
dead the car the dance well it is a
beautiful sunday morning and we've got a
dapper bunch of lads in the car
all right guys you ready for church yep
yep okay well guys did you have a lovely
time at george
yeah it was very nice and some lovely
people invited us over for lunch and uh
so we're gonna go do that
sneak a bit yeah
put some cream on there look at that
it's like an ice cream cone it's very
nice
you ladies having a good time oh yeah oh
say goodbye to friends boys
all right thank you
[ __ ] quick get in the house before the
mages get us protect your legs
what a great day today was it just so
fun to hang out with people from church
to eat food but it's a little hot so to
cool the boys bed down a little bit
i've got a frozen water bottle so we're
gonna let them get into a nice cool bed
and i will see you guys in the morning
we're going camping tomorrow
well good morning me and becca i've
decided to go on a breakfast date
we're in this beautiful little scottish
town of kilmery in the argyle region
this place has got breakfast and we can
get haggis with our eggs well there we
go we got breakfast so this right here
is haggis it's made from the internal
organs of sheep and it's got oatmeal in
it it's actually really good it tastes
kind of like a mild nutty sausage and
this right here is black pudding which
is made from blood and it tastes a
little bit like stuffing
[Music]
oh look a tackle
shop got some fishing gear should we
head back home and relieve melanie of
the children let's go save melanie oh
becca was that a lovely morning that was
lovely i loved it
excellent well i better go get packed i
got some camping to do
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome to barbara mueller's farm shop
look at guys they've got curiosity cola
dandelion burdock we're gonna get a get
a rose lemonade all right let's do one
scoop there's one scoop
i kind of do would this be cool for
winter camping
smells good
okay
yeah don't spill on it
it's a lemon polenta it's kind of like a
sweet lemony cornbread
i'm experiencing being a sheep
it's a tom and sheep's clothing
that looks huge
that's all good
a lot of people don't realize this but
scotland is one of the best places in
the world to go camping not only is it
wild and beautiful and open it also has
the best camping laws anywhere here in
scotland you can go on private land or
public land without needing any permits
or permission you can hike bike even
camp build campfires all that stuff is
completely legal whether the land is
private or public
as long as you use some good common
sense and practice and leave no trace
camping you can go wherever you want and
explore this beautiful country it's
really one of the few places in the
world where you can just put on a
backpack and go anywhere your feet can
take you
there's a shipwreck there on the beach
oh yes the old wooden boat
oh wow the deck collapsed
oh that is a piece of pottery you look
at that
tom see this
they would take sheep's wool and dip it
in tar and they would jam it in between
the wood and that's what keep the water
out
that's cool
oh look at the cute little fuzzy sheep
look at that old building you wanna go
check it out
well this is just how they make windows
when you're making a house out of rocks
make the windows with a little bit of
slate
okay watch out silly don't do it stop
stop do your squishing
[Music]
hi
oh really
that's the people that own this land
that we're crossing and turns out
they're outdoor boys fans so uh we gotta
we gotta beat some fans here in scotland
let's keep going to the castle
i made it to the castle
this castle is almost 500 years old
oh look at that
stairs
yeah this is the toilet
the
fireplace defended
oh this is awesome
this castle was destroyed in battle
during the coveting wars around the
1700s the mcdougall clan
had this castle and uh they ended up
having to surrender because of lack of
water and they were promised if they
surrendered they wouldn't be killed and
they surrendered and then they just
murdered everybody
these windows
absolutely gorgeous spot for a castle
yeah that would be dirty business trying
to attack this castle
would you like to go down to the beach
and see if we can build a fire yeah
all right maybe we can do some fishing
too come on let's do it
no no there's plenty of poop down there
you don't need to carry any poop
[Music]
that little spoon rigged up we got on
these rocks and see if we can't catch a
bullet
look at that beautiful little fish
that's such a pretty fish
i've already gotten like six or seven
strikes in ten casts there's tons of
them in here
really really oh
you got it
lift up your tip you have to tip
oh
wow look at that that's a nice little
pollock can you see mine would you
rather eat that or hot dogs
you okay oh jake
oh did you play in the tide pool
and you got all wet
oh okay well we better go get you warmed
up well let's get a fire going okay
there you go jake are you warmer
you got this little canned spaghetti
noodles like this raw it's a
spaghetti dog
you guys like your hot dogs
got some welsh cakes here
there you go
some fresh pollock
hey do you want some of this
oh i can't see
[Applause]
well if i put you on my shoulders oh why
am i my fishing pole
i'll watch this let's take this out here
aren't you going head upstairs i'll
bring up the stuff
oh
[Music]
it's rolling
freeze tonight would you like some
dessert mini battenburg cakes you know
the historic sites are nice but it's
things like this that keep me coming
back to the uk oh thank you listen do
you guys want to sleep here tonight or
do you want to sleep outside the castle
outside it's a bit spooky isn't it so
apparently it was the campbell clan that
burned and sacked this castle and
murdered all of its occupants after they
surrendered and uh coincidentally that's
the clan that i'm related to so uh
yeah
all right watch out guys
yeah obi-wan kenobi's scottish so we
should we should watch obi-wan kenobi
today right guys kidnap an imperial
senator's child all right guys it's late
we gotta get to bed i'll see you guys in
the morning
[Music]
the sun gets up early here in scotland
and i'm just enjoying
this view
[Music]
nice hot bacon sandwich
well
absolutely no charring no damage
it's exactly the way we want to leave it
thomas jacobs
[Music]
all right guys you ready for the hike
back yeah
all right let's do it
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
go see mama hi
[Music]
oh my
carolina
[Music]
[Music]
this will work nicely
time to take my lovely wife out on a
date
and i have the greatest hosh podge of
clothing there is i've got a nice dandy
jacket here pair of jeans grunden shoes
how long is becca's happy that's all it
matters
see what we got
bread
we got some pate and some oat cakes
all right
i love a place with the view
all right guys that was a lovely day
but
it is late and i am exhausted i'll see
you guys in the morning
hey leon
all right guys we're in the northwest of
scotland i'm here with leon with
wildwood bushcraft we're gonna go do
some survival camping and foraging and
uh just all sorts of fun things leon
here has an awesome survival school and
you can come here and learn all sorts of
survival techniques i'll put a link in
the video description below and we came
here and did a trip with him two years
ago yeah we had so much fun we decided
to come back and give it another try
a deserted island
in the middle of a lock in scotland
we're going to walk around the island
and kind of explore and see what's on
the island
a
group of people over there are sea
trekking and they're hiking they jump in
the water swim to the next island hike
then jump in the water and swim to shore
and hike basically triathloners who
don't like bicycles they're heading off
to that next little group of rocks right
over there
oh that looks so cold
looks like they made it across
oh that's hardcore
yeah yeah exactly
it's like very um it's got like a little
rosette yeah the flower and it's very
spongy so it kind of contains quite a
lot of water
here in scotland there's a lot of peat
in the ground so any standing water is
going to be dark and have that tanning
peat flavor to it so if you can drink it
out of the moss it's going to be better
than drinking out of a puddle
yeah you got you found some wood sorrel
yeah see this little plant looks like
clover kind of it's called wood sorrel
the wood sorrel has kind of a tangy
rhubarb aftertaste it's really subtle
it's nice come on enough wood sorrel
come on spark that comes off obviously
you don't want to damage the tree you
just take it off where it's coming off
this is very good for starting fires
yeah yeah yeah but it also it will burn
up very fast
well we got a crab pot and we want to
set it out today and we found a spot
with a bunch of limpets so we're gonna
go and uh catch some limpets for crab
bait and of course you can also eat
limpets
oh you got him got him
oh here's another one
oh look at the size of those have you
ever had limpet tikka masala no oh well
hey i'm not gonna be able to say that
tomorrow okay
oh yeah collapsible one as we need to
make sure it's not too much excess
you guys gather some seaweed for lunch
yeah i got
well rat
yeah it's supposed to look a little bit
like intestines when it's lying in the
water
there's some stinging metal going in the
pot there
yeah you got makeup five nine
all right we got a scottish bannock here
with some gut weed and channel rack
hmm
that is good
it might not come yeah i'll come back to
you yeah
all right we got the stinging nettle tea
here we're gonna try
i think somebody a lot more vogue than
me would say it has earthy undertones
but nobody knows what that means so you
know
all right well we finished up lunch and
we're gonna head down to the beach and
uh try a little survival exercise we're
going to see if we can take some flotsam
and jetson that might wash up on shore
make a raft out of it
now i like to sort of present it to
everest doing it as a bit of a challenge
you want you want to make a raft
yeah what's your idea buddy i think you
have seen these handles
we can take the rope and tie them
together uh-huh somehow tie these attach
these ones to the back uh-huh
here should we test it out yeah
drop her in tie-hop on it
just tie a rope on you we're gonna go
really shallow
i'm impressed first off that was your
idea to put the handles together
yeah
there you go
oh that was fun well leon baited that
crap out with the limpets and put it out
there a couple hours ago and uh we're
gonna go and check it and just see if we
got any crabs or lobsters or anything in
the pot
oh no don't ram mr leon you naughty
child
okay that might have been mostly the
wind okay
there you go tom
yeah pull that buoy up and throw it in
the back of the boat
oh is there something in there
oh a little sugar if you want to send it
back yeah
hi
well thank goodness for exoskeletons
look at this we're like on deadliest
catch we're crab fishermen now
we got the rubber pants and everything
oh there's some big boys out here
look at the size of that thing
i kicked this limpet off the rock and it
flew about 10 feet through the air and
hit tommy in the back of the head
i think he's dead
look at a size comparison here
look at that thing that thing's like two
inches across
gut weed right here yeah
that's the gut weed so you get some of
the gut weed
get the good stuff that's really gutty
there you go
yeah there we go
oh we caught something
there we go we got a little ember there
this way please wait do you still see
that ember
it looks like this
oh
we're going to have uh some foraged
seafood curry here we're gonna have some
razor clams limpets
go and uh throw them in with the seaweed
[Music]
leon's got some razor clams he harvested
a little while ago this bit that comes
out of here
so the foot is the best bit of kind of
guts here yeah yeah there goes the razor
clams
the steel little piece right here
nice that is nice
[Music]
of course you can't have curry without a
little bread to go with it right
[Music]
look at that that actually looks like a
proper little curry there
there we go razor clam limpet seaweed
tikka masala
that's good yeah you can't can't go to
the british isles without having a good
curry on a scale of 1 to 10 how does
this compare to other limpet curries you
had i'm stuck in a 10.
we'll have to do a pig nut uh vindaloo
next time
what do you think you think it's about
bedtime yeah
okay
tell me have you had a fun day yeah yeah
i've said that the strip is ending
are you waked up yes are you
a lovely day
leon thank you so much we had such a
great time thank you we're done
young man
welcome home my dears the next day all
right guys it's another beautiful day in
scotland and we're gonna go on a nice
long drive to the isle of skye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well it was a lovely nice long drive
but we have trashed this rental house
and we have got to get it cleaned up
because we're checking out tomorrow
morning and driving to ireland
wake up boys wake up wake up we're going
to ireland we're going to ireland
ireland
[Music]
that's the bridge from the harry potter
movies
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
yeah isn't that nice
we have an excellent view and it's warm
no no you guys wouldn't like it it's
it's kind of like ice cream you don't
you don't like that
wow that is a big boat
all right guys we're on the piano ferry
from scotland to northern ireland you
see we got on the ferry here the
southern part of scotland went across
the straits and we're almost to northern
ireland just a little bit north of
belfast
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a castle across the street a
beach next door
lighthouses
[Music]
ah
i had to order a five terabyte hard
drive i've already done almost two
terabytes of filming on this trip
look at this oh my goodness
[Applause]
together i think this living room has
more square footage than some of the
places we rented
nice oh my goodness there's another
bedroom upstairs
hey melanie how about this one you want
this one
big big kitchen look at this they got
some
they got a little care package just some
soda farls oh that's really nice
remember correctly too this wasn't that
expensive this was actually a reasonably
priced house this thing is like
six times bigger than any of the other
houses we rented this was hip and
cutting edge in the 70s i can tell you
now look at this back porch here
right up against the ocean
i've got a lot of unpacking to do and
kids to put to bed so i'm gonna put this
up i'll see you guys in the morning
well guys it is a beautiful sunday
morning and everyone's still asleep so
i'm going to try to get some breakfast
ready for everyone and since we're in
ireland i'm going to make french toast
yeah why not
and french toast
it's
available
town pizza with tiger crust
i don't know what a tiger crust is well
it's sunday here in northern ireland so
we are gonna go to church
there's the castle look at that right
across the street
all right i'm putting the camera down
well we met some friends at church we
got him over we're gonna hang out and
have some dinner and just take it easy
it's a low-key spaghetti diet i could
spill on this carpet and nobody would
even know her
so it's like they're really going to do
it
thomas
you having fun playing with friends yes
guys guys you want some junk food
aunt melanie bought a bunch of these
candy flying saucers here do you guys
want to try one yeah
it's like a rice paper ravioli with
pixie stick dust inside
have you guys had fun playing yeah
hey guys thank you so much for coming it
was so fun to have you did you have fun
yeah
let's go bye bye bye guys have a drive
home well it is late and it is time to
get the kids to bed i will see you guys
tomorrow because we got a lot of fun
stuff planned
all right guys we're in northern ireland
right now and we're gonna drive about
two hours south to dublin and see
another country
we are now in the republic of ireland
really the only thing that tells you
you've crossed the border is that the
signs change from miles per hour to
kilometers per hour burn poo
all right we're going to stop for lunch
we've got deep fried brie here you want
you want to try a piece of that
like that
[Music]
all right guys welcome to dublin
[Music]
oh that's a tight barking spot they're
like as long as a car
what kind of ice cream you want
okay
mango i'm getting brown bread there you
go buddy
[Music]
oh it's got a spider on it oh it does
watch out guys
that's good
do you want to try the brown bread
[Music]
the season is good dude
we tend not to go to big cities with the
kids
just keeping them out of traffic and
keeping them from getting lost is
stressful so
we tend to like the more real places but
every once in a while we go
the molly malone statue
this is dublin castle so we're gonna go
in and check it out
[Music]
we just saw a seal swimming out in the
ocean by our house
yeah there's a whole bunch of fish in
there oh i see them
well it's just the end of another level
she's dancing i know she she does it all
the time
well is the end of a lovely lovely day
all right we're gonna go explore
northern ireland a lot more tomorrow see
you guys then all right guys eat quick
we're leaving eat
well today we're headed northwest and
we're gonna go explore the northern
coast of northern ireland
all right guys we're here with becky
here at it's brockhammen farms and uh
we're gonna do a little farm tour we've
got goats we've got calves
but we're gonna go on a little foraging
walk first i've got it let's go let's do
some foraging
is that a walls it is a rose well done
you can make teas out of it syrups and
then if you wait to autumn this little
bit in the center
turns into a rose hip which you can make
into syrup
oh you guys know what that is
yeah this is a potent poisonous plant so
this is the honeysuckle
[Laughter]
yeah these are wild strawberries hey
jake you want one here try that one
yeah
the flowers are used in a traditional
gypsy remedy for colds and flus when
it's combined with yarrow and mint
yes so pine is actually edible pollen
the bark the sap it's all edible
it pokes my tub
this is a pine resin itself if you want
to have a smell horny ooh i love that
yeah that does smell good yeah
pick it and smell it and tell me what
you think it smells like
this is pineapple weed yeah sweet so
that's the chamomile thing
so you can have a go at least you want
to taste some of the flowers on me and
it's also that's fine
this is sorrel if you have a nibble on
it you'll know it's sorrel yeah it's
like kind of almost like a little bit of
rhubarb flavor to it yeah
you can pick some of the dandelions but
i'm rich with plants you're rich with
plants he's minted this is called
plantain
plantain is really good if you get a
thorn or a sting see all the green juice
that's coming out uh-huh sound like this
and that is your nature's bandage
so do you guys have this going looks
like lupin it's called sticky willy
so we can use this in our vinegar as
well because it's really good ready
you've got some water in here
oh like with the mouth
oh that's kind of brilliant
this is a kelly kettle this is a little
irish camping device here got the bowl
with a little hole to let the air in and
the flame comes up in the middle of the
thermos and then there's this double
wall with water inside and it allows you
to boil water really efficiently you can
also get little accessories to cook off
the top and everything
chop up the pine so this gives it a
better flavor i know
so knuckle pesto's a really nice quick
thing to make
all right the nettle pesto baby yeah
tell me what do you think
yeah yeah chickpea pesto's great
are we gonna try the pine tea with a
little bit of ginger in here
yeah size make your own vinegar you can
take it home and then strain it out
i'm punching the nettles off oh my god
what if that's effective either what you
got in there you got some elder flower
you've got some dandelions
and they've got stinky nuts
you got stinging nettle in there too
so we're just topping it up with vinegar
and then we can let that sit for about
four weeks
at the top that is pretty good
[Music]
oh those are some tough forms these guys
will call me me i'll go try to eat my
finger he's pretty much creamy
you can give him a strike
is this fun tommy
so these guys have just arrived when
they're a bit bigger they'll join the
other guys out in the field you add
knocks and stuff and then they'll go
right oh yeah oh that feels weird um
yeah this is a salami it's kind of like
a pepperoni but not not as spicy this is
like squash
so that's made with the aldefaz
i love goat i don't want any of the
recipes for this oh thank you very much
that's very
and as always we'll put the link to
their website down in the video
description below if you want to do this
too well guys was that awesome yeah
tommy do you want a pet goat now yes do
you want a thousand pet goats yes
we're here at the giants causeway in
northern ireland
[Music]
it's the same geological formation as
fingal's cave in scotland which we went
to earlier but this one's a little bit
more popular because you can actually
drive to it
a little bit of water
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right guys you want to go check out
this rope bridge
killing me watch out for puffin attacks
that cool
there you go
there you go
it's kind of bouncy isn't it
there you go
so this bridge is about 300 years old
and fishermen built it to access the
shore
you can see it's just solid sheer cliffs
all the way down so you come down onto
this little island
and they can get down there
and access the shore there's a little
cottage right down there
that was cool but man we burned up a
whole day haven't we it went by fast
it's brown
lots of brown good morning guys it is a
beautiful day
i think i need to go diving
so
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna make the most delicious
sandwiches here and i've got this
awesome salami from brock diamond farms
and they've got a summer chutney and we
got some brilliant baguettes and
tomatoes and one of the things i love
about the uk is this stuff is so cheap
this baguette was about 75 cents this
wedge of brie cost about a dollar and 10
cents this would be closer to six to
seven dollars in the united states
we're just going to go up the road 10
minutes to a castle ward which is
another national heritage trust site
look at this crazy tree
look at the thorns on this it's like
giant angry rhubarb
garden who got who got stung by stinging
nettles spitting on my hand
just spit on it
thanks for spitting on me dad
it's only been what two hours
yes okay we've been hiking for a little
bit and melanie has the map i have no
idea where she's leading us
nope tommy's already dead leave his
corpse for the foxes
so this is castle ward and we're gonna
go check it out
look at that there's a bear look at the
secret door behind him
it's designed like the bookshelf just a
sticker oh that's cool
yeah it's taxidermied squirrels that
look like they're boxing
you guys like your ice cream
yeah yeah
well it has been a lovely day but i am
going to try to get some sleep call it a
night
and uh tomorrow we've got some really
fun things just me and becca and get to
go out and do some do some fun stuff
together so i'll see you guys then
all right
melanie is babysitting the children all
day and we are gonna go do some fun
stuff including fishing
we're here at glen keane trout fisheries
[Music]
i would just start at number one and
cast this side of it you know that's the
excitement of clean king you don't know
if it's going to be a two pound fish or
a 22 pound fish
oh look at that
there you go
that was another beautiful fish the
average fish in this pond are huge
there you go
babe probably one of the smaller fish
here but what a feisty guy
they get up to 22 pounds here
that's the size of a king salmon you
know glenn keane and these other
fisheries they'll rent you gear lots of
friendly people around to give you tips
to show you what to do it's just a
really fun experience baby do you have a
good time have a great time
as always we'll put links in the video
description below
me and megan just got pulled over by the
cops here in northern ireland
apparently they didn't like my driving
and they had me take a breath test
the officer asked me if i'd ever taken a
breathalyzer before and i told him yes
the truth is i actually own like six of
them before i did youtube i was a
criminal defense attorney for about 10
11 years and i specialized in dui
defense but sure helps when you've had
absolutely nothing to drink so we all
we're all good
all right guys we're here in belfast and
we found a cool looking little antique
shop and i'll tell you if you like
antique shops in the u.s you'll love
antique shops in europe they're way
cooler here
oh here we go yeah that's that's coming
let's make it there's there's mortars in
here
these are casings from world war ii this
is this is the plug that goes into
grenades giant bruce lee statue i never
knew i needed one maybe that's an
artillery shell
oh gosh
forensic science school of the guy the
guy that was murdered yeah a gun with
bayonet
oh it's a two-headed calf
just a big thing of shiley's
i need a i need an anvil like that
oh look at they have not one not two
but five riot shields
everyone in the family could get a riot
shield look at chamber pot i should get
that from melanie oh
oh this does not disappoint this is the
coolest antique shop i have ever been in
period
i know i've already gotten enough pelts
pigskin
was that a red deer
look at that
right right in front of the uh raptor
with the santa claus outfit as the
machine gun
oh
yeah there's a skeleton back there
[Music]
that's a
grizzly bear rug
oh man
that's got the plates in it
look it's a zombie deer i love the
amount of taxidermy going on here
oh actually okay i'll tell you what i've
poked my head into a lot of antique
stores over the years and this by far is
the coolest one i've ever been to do you
agree it was very cool all right so
check out the emporium on the square and
i'll put a link in the video description
below
hey melanie
what is this
oh that's so cool
look at that she's a date on it yeah
jubilee 1887.
queen victoria's jubilee 40 years she
was it was 1837 was when she was crowned
do you like that i do i really like it
hey boys come here what do you think
this is those are bullet shows from
world war ii
these are bullets that were shot during
the war
time flies check out how far the tide's
gone out we've got a big old negative
tide
little baby crab
put it back well tommy have you had a
good time here in northern ireland yeah
well tomorrow morning we're taking a
ferry we're heading back over to great
britain and tomorrow we're going to be
staying in a castle like a real castle
i'll see you guys in the morning
third
[Music]
[Music]
well how's that for a castle guys
[Music]
yeah i think we're up there
no it's just that disney
this is bagel i think this is our room
yep look at this
oh my goodness
rebecca what do you think you like this
this is very cool we're all settled into
our castle hotel room here i think it's
time for dinner
we got our dinner reservations and we're
just hanging out here in the drawing
room looking over the menu
oh nice nice
here your name nathan you did it like a
boss
it's kind of like carrot curry soup do
you like that mousse
goodness look at this
oh excellent do you like the sticky
toffee pudding
it's good you got some treacle tart look
at that
it's a strawberry souffle can i have a
taste
yes
oh yeah
hey have you enjoyed dinner it was
lovely i love dollywood
well good morning guys it is a beautiful
day becca's sitting here sketching in
the cloister while tommy listens to
audiobooks cause everyone's taking it
easy we're gonna go down get some
breakfast and then we're gonna check out
we're gonna go to our next property we
got a cool place we're gonna be staying
tonight all right guys we're going down
to breakfast see those little spots with
the shields
those are toilets where the light is
there used to be a hole that would go
out
out of the building
oh yeah you like it you like your
chocolate croissant
all right guys we're checking out and
we're gonna head in the car and drive
down to darley darleydale england a
little bit of a drive
i'm really glad we did that
all right guys we're headed about three
hours south through some of the most
beautiful countryside
[Music]
this looks nice
nice big kitchen look at this patio yeah
oh that's gonna get you mind your head
no joke about that
gorgeous little river
well this is a lovely place but we are
hungry and we're gonna go get some
indian food does that sound nice let's
do it
got a lovely looking indian restaurant
here there's a good pompano
yeah that's like a really sweet curry
with a really sweet naan i mean that it
really does taste like a dessert
it's delicious that was crazy delicious
we are so full that was the best indian
food i've ever had
i'm sorry sorry but we have some good
stuff
we have spice but it has a [ __ ] it's
been nice and low-key
but it's late now time to go to bed i'll
see you guys in the morning
you want some cereal get your shoes on
it's another beautiful sunday and we're
gonna head off to church
all right shall we go inside
all right guys let's put the camera down
did you guys make some new friends
yeah you guys were tearing it up with
all the little boys in there
what is a wonderful low-key sunday we're
just eating some dinner relaxing
because tomorrow we've got some fun
stuff planned but anyway i'll see you
guys tomorrow
oh my goodness
what a beautiful day well you know what
today i want to fly fish that river but
i didn't bring a fly rod you know
something
becca's kind of wanted to get a fly rod
ever since we went fly fishing in
montana so i think it's time to go do
that
all right becky are you ready to try out
a fire iron you know just like harry
potter swish and flick
you got yourself a new fly rod i got a
fly around awesome cheers
well we're here in bakewell which is
famous for the bakewell tart and the
bakewell pudding and we've got to get
one before we leave or melanie will feel
very sad
we get the little little mini ones look
at that oh becca did we buy way too many
cars we did
what it's really good
all right i think it's time to do a
little fishing
here you go baby hop on in okay oh my
god
that's your fishing rod oh thank you
well aim for that one that's a good one
to practice
you got one yeah
that is a nice
british grayling
oh
oh he's off he's off he was like 16
inches
look at that
there we go my first british brown trout
was that a pretty fish yeah
well becca's doing a little fly fishing
i am going to go ahead and rig up a rig
for barbel a little ground bait here
see that
has a little bite alarm that screws into
a bank stick but we've got to bring it
so i'm going to try to jerry-rig
something take that little ball of paste
and put it around my lead and i got a
little bit of a hot dog on the end of a
hair rig there
there you go let that sit for just a
little bit see if there's any marvel in
there but while we fish i am going to go
and make some hot dogs
all right it's dessert time it's a baby
like your big ol tart it's good hmm
oh something's going on there look at
that oh come on
oh it broke got into the snags and broke
this off
well me and tom are just waiting for a
bite i can see fish rising right here in
front of me so i'm gonna pull out the
fly rod and see if we can't pick up a
few
come here buddy i got one
yeah
my first british grayling
yes
[Applause]
well that guy didn't want to hold still
for the camera but another beautiful
british grayling not as big as mom's
though
hey tom tom fish odd great good be
gentle be gentle with it
yeah it's a rainbow it's a nice rainbow
that is nice
look at that
wild trout
look at that
tommy high five that was a big rainbow
buddy
well guys it's getting late and the
sun's setting so i think we're going to
call it here we had a good time you had
a great time you like your fishing rod i
love my fishing dress
look at this
all right well melanie had originally
planned a bunch of historic stuff to
check out today but she's all sick and
in bed so we're going to kind of soldier
on without her we're going to go to the
city of nottingham
[Music]
no it's like underground
so guys this is the city of caves under
nottingham it's a large complex of over
800 caves under the city so way back in
the old days people would carve caves
and underground tunnels out of the
sandstone and make homes and businesses
we're going to do a little tour this
creepy yes
oh oh no
this is nathan's bedroom right here they
put a little candle right in there
that'd be like their lighting
oh yeah a little well flashlight down
there this is where they had the tannery
and they'd fill this up with chemicals
to tan hides this is a bomb shelter so
when the nazis would bomb the city
people could hide down here how to be
feminine and fashionable while wearing
your gas mask
a world war ii bomb
oh yeah look at this you can see all the
marks where they cut it out with chisels
all right guys you ready for the
national justice museum
yeah cops would have them
nathan's listening to a story about a
guy who got convicted of killing a
scotsman in york on sunday apparently it
was legal on saturdays but not on sunday
give me a hand guys look how many rungs
there are right yeah so that's how many
people would be in here
that's your punishment you have to turn
that crank all day long
where they would lock up ladies who
committed crimes
like there's poop in the chamber pond i
think it smells like hospitals
oh this is the dungeons
oh it's a little door right we dug out
of jail so this is how much they would
charge them for being in debtor's prison
for their food and room and board funny
thing they still do this in virginia you
get locked up in jail they charge you to
be in jail
see this goes around your waist and it
locks your hands to your side
oh yeah
this is a ship like when you were
transported to australia
take this
and you put this around your feet you
can't put your legs far apart but this
would be a steel ball you have to drag
that around with you
a scolds bridle and that would keep you
from being able to talk got nathan in
the stocks this is a branding iron it's
an r for road which means a dishonest
person
does this look a little bit like dad's
old workplace
you ready to be a juror
i want you to come down here
well guys was that cool
yeah we uh you got to be magistrates in
a trial didn't you you testified against
your mom and got her header put in the
stocks and they were going to throw
things at my face well that was cool
all righty we're back
we've had a great time visiting the
museums but i
want to do some fishing
swung by the fishing tackle shop and a
big wiggly bag of maggots here kind of
soft and fuzzy
well there you go we got becca's come
down to join us she's gonna do a little
fly fishing with us it's a good looking
woman right there
i was wondering what was getting my bait
i'll tell you what guys it may not look
like much but this is one of the funnest
days we've had on the trip it's just so
beautiful out here it's so low-key
that is a nice brown trout
well welcome to another amazingly
beautiful day where are we headed
melanie the workhouse
all right guys we're here at the
workhouse yes the nichols family has
gone bust so we're gonna learn about
what it's like to be poor in old england
you've seen me use this before right
that's right
we just need to find two more of these
and we're set what do you think nathan
[Applause]
oh they should sell these in the gift
shop
see how cool it is down here even though
it's hot outside they would hang up
their meat here
hey guys you want to go see the school
these are victorian era ipads
[Music]
guys realize you've just come to one of
those time warps
[Music]
that's cool
yeah there you go nathan what do they
call grilled cheese sandwiches in the uk
toasties what do you think was this a
pretty place to eat lunch it was
beautiful this is south wellminster
it's time to say goodbye to aunt melanie
we're dropping her off at the rail
station and she's going to be flying out
of here a little before we do
all right melanie we'll see
we head back to the house
oh hi sweetie we're here mom is busy
packing up and getting everything ready
for tomorrow so uh me and tommy we're
gonna go walk across the bridge to a pub
pick up food for the family
so tom what's been your favorite part of
the trip so far
tom don't fall off there and break your
neck the day before we're flying out
you're only allowed to hospitalize
yourself on days we aren't traveling
have you had a good day i've had a great
day i've had a great trip
[Music]
was that fun yeah
[Music]
i need to make
oh was that a fun trip it was wonderful
well listen if you guys enjoy watching
these travel videos make sure to check
out our travel adventure playlist we
have a ton of these videos and i'll put
a link in the video description below to
that playlist so definitely check that
out and don't forget to click subscribe
to the outdoor boys youtube channel we
put out new videos every saturday
morning
now everybody demand it's midnight
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]